let's face it ladies and gentlemen we
live in a 24-hour news cycle there's so
much breaking news it's hard to process
all of it well we found a way to put the
day's news in perspective with the help
of our good friend mr. Deon Cole and a
segment called Dion breaks it down
[Music]
let's get started this week this week
the Bible movie Exodus gods and Kings
was criticized for casting christian
bale to play moses instead of using a
middle-eastern actor yeah all white
people pay in to make this movie yes yes
mostly yes is there a Middle Eastern
actor more famous than Christian Bale I
don't think so no do you think anyone is
gonna pay to see hair on Kumar go to
Egypt then let Batman play Moses to tell
the critics to shut the hell up
[Applause]
[Music]
my next story after after claiming the
company was misleading customers some
attorneys in San Francisco and Los
Angeles are calling for a ban on the
rideshare company uber uber pick up
black passengers yes of course it does
yeah for less money than calves that
don't pick up black passengers yes I
believe so yeah can you tell those
attorneys to catch a rat to shut the
hell up
[Applause]
[Music]
yesterday Pope Francis gave a speech
warning his followers not to become
slaves to materialism during the
Christmas season the baby Jesus get
gifts yes he got he got them from the
wise men yes the baby Jesus turn him
down no we did it
and when my son doesn't get his gift
since the Pope don't come wipe his tears
away probably not no can you tell Pope
Francis
nevermind
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
finally after watching an NBA game
during their us visit the royal couple
posed for a picture with LeBron James
and British officials say James violated
royal protocol by putting his arm around
Princess Kate is the King more powerful
than a prince yes is LeBron James
nicknamed King James that is right yes
it is and weren't they all King James
Court I guess they were yeah then tell
those snooty stuck-up inbred wannabe
Downton Abbey krumitz nuts and krumpers
to shuttle
[Music]
here and coal everybody
[Applause]
you